kaka est maintenant pierre perret
dia féret
c'est moi qui poserait la première
question si vous permettez répondez moi
honnêtement est-ce que vous avez répété
non justement c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire pierre perret vous êtes fait
connaître au début des années 60 avec
des chansons gauloise parfois même
grivoises puis vos ritournelle sont
devenus de plus en plus militante
vous avez commencé à écrire vous êtes
mis à faire des dictionnaires des
anthologies vous êtes entré au conseil
supérieur de la langue française et
aujourd'hui vous êtes un monument
national qu'est ce que je vous dis que
je suis dégoûté il ya même des écoles et
des rues qui porte votre nom c'est
incroyable n'ont jamais j'ai pensé une
seconde au quart du millième de ce qui
m'est arrivé parce que j'ai toujours été
un un enfant rêveur à ceux ci me des
contemplatifs finalement j'étais heureux
de tous la première fois que papa m'a
demandé quand j'avais mon petit
certificat d'études en poche
maintenant qu'est ce que tu veux faire
chez 10 mai - papa rien suffirait est ce
que vous avez pensé temps franck un jour
vous seriez à tout le monde en parle et
que vous auriez droit
un triomphe romain
et voilà alors heureusement
heureusement vous êtes toujours rester
extérieur à votre personnage public qui
vous avez toujours cette simplicité
malgré un beau succès oui je trouve pas
grand mérite à ça parce que d'abord je
pense que c'est très trop fatigant
d'être différent jouer la star sait ou
patti gré oui vous jouez un personnage à
longueur de journée je ne sais pas ce
qui arrive à le faire sont des gens
beaucoup plus fort que moi 120